our next speaker is also going to talk
about uh
topics that relate to DARPA she did a
lot of research for them and through
some of her discoveries
she will actually help impact uh
citizens Health please welcome out
Alicia Jackson
[Applause]
thank you in 2010 when I arrived at
DARPA
we were faced with a following problem
which is that the military sends
millions of its members across the globe
and in many of those places there is no
medical infrastructure so if somebody
Falls ill there's no Minute Clinic or
Physician's office or even a
phlebotomist to take a blood sample and
so we were faced with the challenge of
how do we diagnose this individual
in a robust Accurate Way no matter where
in the world they may be located and so
we invested in two technologies One
enable that individuals to collect their
own blood sample and number two enable
that sample to be shipped back to a
clinical lab without having to be packed
on ice
and as those Technologies began to pay
off we began to realize that it could
have a huge impact Way Beyond the
military but on personalized medicine
today the conversation has been
completely constrained around genetic
sequencing we'll sequence your genome
we'll look at your variations and we'll
figure out what your risk profile is
but what you really want to know or what
I want to know is am I developing that
disease am I developing it tomorrow am I
currently developing it and the
challenge is that genetics tells us fate
it doesn't tell a state
and that's actually the information that
we want to measure and to capture
now the genome is largely static and
what you want is the dynamic information
that's carried by the RNA and the
proteins that are being not only
expressed off the genome but are being
impacted by your environment and that
are actually a reflection of your
real-time state of health and this
information is dynamic it's not static
now you may say to me Alicia while we
already collect this Dynamic information
we do but we don't throughout the course
of Our Lives from birth to death we only
measure these biomarkers a handful of
times we measure them at some
age-specific checkups and then we
measure them when we're ill
and we don't compare them to ourselves
in our healthy state but we only compare
them to when we are a population average
which is not reflective of ourselves
what would be much more powerful is if
we could track these levels dynamically
frequently over time
in periods of wellness and in periods of
illness and through this information
begin to be able to develop the ability
to actually predict not only disease
onset
but our treatment course and the impact
of those treatments
let me make this very specific there is
a cancer biomarker known as cancer
antigen 125 and its novarian cancer
biomarker and it's uses a threshold test
so if your level of ca125 is above the
threshold you're considered to have
cancer but most clinicians will tell you
it's way too late
the other challenge is that even if you
test below the threshold
most early cancer patients measure
already below the threshold
the result being that most people who
are then diagnosed with ovarian cancer
are already in the latest stages when
it's least curable
what's going on here
what's going on is that we're using a
population average and assuming that
that average threshold is the same for
every single one of us
the other challenge is that all of all
the women in this room are levels of CA
125 vary anywhere from 70 to 47 to 40
percent over the course of a month
and so what would be much more effective
is if we could track those levels over
time and understand what is normal for
us
and indeed there was a group in the UK
who just published a study last year
that looked at 50 000 women over the
course of a decade in which they measure
their levels of ca125 as infrequently as
every year and as frequently as every 12
weeks
and the result was astounding
what they found was that regardless of
the initial and final magnitude
of the ca-125 measurement
if they saw the measurement double over
the period of six months they were able
to diagnose 86 cases of ovarian cancer
doubling the effectiveness of the
biomarker
and this isn't just the case for CA 125
and ovarian cancer but it's the case for
many biomarkers that are currently
correlated with things like
neurodegenerative disease other types of
cancer and oncology and cardiovascular
disease
and so what we can sense is that we're
very close to a near future where just
by changing the way that we measure
biomarkers that are already FDA approved
we don't have to discover anymore we can
dramatically increase their
effectiveness
but it's predicated on being able to
take this frequent blood sample and as
any of you know who've given a blood
sample recently or gone to a blood draw
Center the user experience is atrocious
what we need is a way that is as
seamless to our course of care
as when your doctor uses a stethoscope
or a tongue depressor on you you want
something that can be implemented
quickly and seamlessly
even so that you can do it in your own
home
and the key Insight that we had at DARPA
and that I am currently building right
now is that those same technologies that
enabled us to acquire and transport a
sample from a soldier anywhere in the
world are the same technologies that can
enable us to acquire a sample anywhere
in our Health Care system and anywhere
in our daily lives thank you